why do you think we're just constantly
obsessed
with wanting an easy solution to complex
problems
what's actually happened here is that
there are people
who actually don't want be
straightforward don't want solutions
you see somehow the perpetuation of the
problem
actually suits them
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constant kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people a fascinating
guest we have for you today he was the
chair of the commission which produced
the race and disparities report doctor
tony so welcome back to triggering hi
it's nice to come back again after my
debut
yeah some years ago your debut was a
couple of years ago and then rather more
relaxed
relaxed circumstances
[Laughter]
yeah well you know it's it's been an
interesting uh
ride since i last saw you you know so
yeah things have happened to you i mean
you are an education consultant that's
your thing generating genius as the
charity that's what we talked about last
time and since then the government
uh asked you to produce a report on uh
racial disparities
uh in the uk you produced the report we
had one of your commissioners mercy
morocco on the show to talk about
it yeah uh but uh we were keen to have
you back and thank you for coming back
to talk to us sure
uh what's it been like for you first of
all just on an individual level because
that report was um
not that well
well received means he's doing quite
well then if he's not there no i mean
the the people who need to receive the
government yeah yeah and i think that
we we want them to sort of obviously try
to wreck it you know
put all of the recommendations in place
but
we're we're not apache for government i
mean and and they're going to find
those recommendations tough and
challenging
um for me it it i must admit i think
um in terms of trying to explain
um what happened over that period i
think
that misunderstanding might be
one way of looking at it but i do think
that you know
one of the interesting things about that
is that
i don't know how many people actually
read or read that report
i mean who reads reports in the end and
it's quite interesting that you know
government commissions lots of these
things but
the attention this had was interesting
and obviously it did
happen as you know i mean stimulated by
the george floyd murder
but then it but then it was more than
that because it was about the uk
and what happened here i would say that
um what happened here was an intro i
mean in terms of
um what we were trying to do first of
all before we even get into the reaction
i mean
the reaction was i would i would
disagree with you i don't think it was
actually
all bad i think what happened was that
there were a lot of people who when they
did read it
liked it yeah and were very supportive
of it so we
we have that but yes people
misunderstood it
and i think that was the thing and why
they misunderstood it was really going
back to my debut really with you and i
sort of
they they thought that what they had in
the
in terms of myself and my commissioners
was a bunch of people who were just
basically um you know kind of
i don't know supporters of the tory
party just basically boris's mates or
whatever
and he just cobbled together a few
people and they were going to write a
report for him and he was going to go
home and be happy you know
and actually if they read the report
what they missed was the complete
opposite happened
and and so that so in in effect what
actually happened was that
people responded to what they read in
the garden or in
the other papers but they didn't
actually read the report
so for example you know people say oh i
don't like that report or
they're denying racism or whatever but
they never read it they just said that
so you think wow are we in a world now
where people
are not even going to just look at the
thing you know even
even you know some some pages or some of
the recommendations
but the answer is yes well you know what
i'm thinking
given that not every you're right not
everybody reads reports or very few
people do there'll be people watching
this who
maybe you've got an open mind they
haven't read the report they read some
of the coverage they don't know what
happened
what were some of the key findings and
the key recommendations that you made
well let me tell you what really did
stir up the problem for this and
and why people didn't didn't really
think that they
they they grasped it properly or they
grasped a grasp of it wrongly
was that we first of all we were looking
at four areas really
education employment crime and policing
and health right those are the four
right from the outset we did say
quite clearly in that report that there
was persistent racism in the country
we weren't denying that that came out
strong that'd be the first interesting
thing that came up so that was one of
the first
findings that racism exists and it's
alive but then what we did then was we
said but
you can't just understand racism in
isolation it's connected to lots of
other things so for example
socioeconomic backgrounds becomes
the key element here and then um
you know you look at other things like
the family cultural factors
geography where you live and then what
you do then is you
once you you start looking at those
other variables
and also you bring in the white group
into this because they they
actually happen to be human beings as
well and they're they're they're they're
examined in the mix
then you come out you you emerge with a
report that basically says this that
overall i mean and this is this is sort
of the key finding here
is that um race disparities
exist but racism isn't the major driver
for most of them
the major reason for for most of them
being there so that's a kind of strange
kind of tension because you're saying
that there's a racial disparity but
racism isn't
the key element what really is what is
the key driver in all of this
is your is your his poverty is your
socio-economic background
that's what drives the whole area and
and and if you look at the give you one
particular
group that doesn't um fit in the whole
kind of category also the other thing is
that
you can't actually start i mean it's
another finding we
it's a pretty obvious one that you can't
just lump everybody together so for
example
ethnic minority groups all lump together
so the experience of
an indian doctor in harrow is
is a world away from a taxi driver in
bradford
you know what i mean yeah we categorize
them as asian
yeah you know well these people are
fighting a war back home right but
here they're they're like one group yeah
it doesn't make any sense you know
and so we and but one of the things that
was quite interesting was
and the battle really in schools from my
own area
in education and and and when we when we
cut
it and we said that people were saying
all these black boys have been excluded
and all these black boys are doing so
badly in school but what do we mean by
black because once we cut it and we said
right
let's split black caribbean and black
african
and then there was a world of difference
i mean in terms of exclusion rates
black african boys were were you know
hardly excluded i think like seven in in
ten thousand were being excluded
from africa whereas caribbean was 25 in
10 000
a huge difference and when it came to
the exam results
african um boys which were
i would say in terms of we could
progress eight in
in in school and gcse results way ahead
in fact they were way ahead of white
groups as well
yeah and and caribbean groups were
worse than white groups in terms of some
of the outcomes
so you say here's a racial disparity
you can't no longer talk about black
boys as a whole because they're not the
same what
and and let's be honest these same boys
are in the same classroom they come from
the same estate
they're in front of the same white
teacher yet
these results this you know are
diverging in different directions
so you cannot look you no longer can say
that
the reason for black boys underachieving
in school is teacher racism
you see you have to go somewhere else to
find the answer
and where we where we landed it was to
do with i mean a couple of things really
you can see it it's landed in the
poverty issues yeah
but it's also landed in the family
issues and some cultural issues as well
so for example if you were to then look
at some data around that it's
i mean i want to put a health check on
what i say here because
i do not think it's family style at all
or single mothers to blame
and people will keep saying this i don't
i just think it's
have a recommendation around that as
well but
if you just look at how those families
are set up i mean
63 percent of the black caribbean my
communities who are inverted commerce
are from lone parents 63 percent
the african is 40 and indian is six
then you only have to the conversation
you don't have to
put those issues together in terms of
poverty
you know and it's not that every lone
parent is poor
but the vast majority of them are you
know significant amounts are because of
the situation you're in
and it's not to say you shouldn't be a
single parent but what we should then do
is as the commission is recommend
resources for you so what
what we were finding in terms of
findings then that's the
the key thing you just the thing is
complex you can't just
go out there and say here is this racist
race disparity
equals racism yeah the other thing
and i think this is probably the key
driver geography where you live and we
saw this in this hardly pooled election
that we saw recently
of the of the neighborhood of the 20 big
poor neighborhoods that we have around
the country
19 of them are in the north the poorest
right and obviously a majority of that
is white populations yeah in the poorest
there's also some on the south coast as
well but
the majority of them are in the north
the other thing with that
is that london and the south east
comprise of in when it comes to social
mobility
the highest mobility rates are happening
in london and the south
east so you know if you're a bangladeshi
girl
in tower hamlets you're you're flying in
terms of exam results
if you're a bangladeshi girl in bradford
you you're nearly at the bottom of the
the pecking order so where you live in
the uk
is is the is a key determinant so
what people didn't want to hear was that
message that this thing is complicated
they wanted us to say look tony
look don't don't give us any of this
kind of nonsense this
it's it's racism that is the thing
that's driving this thing
but and i'll come on to that in a minute
but but
but we couldn't just say that because
the evidence didn't take us there
you know you go where the evidence the
evidence took us to somewhere which was
more complicated
and needed needed more sophisticated
answers
now in our world of identity politics if
you come up with anything that's
complicated
like this or say that it's different
variables you can only be one thing
you're either you're in the race camp or
you're out of it
yeah and that's it and if you're out of
it that means you're a race denier
you're a judas you betrayed your race
whatever
whatever
now you know to me i think there's some
links in america here and i was thinking
of this the other day
we're not the same as america and we do
import some of the things that are bad
there in terms of our thinking
but i think african americans and black
which i think has emerged out of here
the group
that is that that looks like it's like
an
equivalent to an african-american is my
my community black caribbean
and that that that is the thing that
sticks out here and people say
oh you're dividing all people and you're
dividing black from one
but the data shows the data is showing
all these elements to be the truth
and we're talking about it and why do
you think it's something as simple as
the fact that there are
that black caribbean especially black
caribbean boys are less likely to grow
up
with a dad in the house and then the
impact that that has
um i'm going to say no
i'm going to throw you that because
people have associated me with trying to
explain away these problems by landing
it on
on on black women as it were and i don't
think it's there i don't think the
problem is there i think
what when we cut this it
is a factor i'm not denying in terms of
poverty and but that would be a factor
for
single white women in in hartlepool you
know it's a
it's a factor for everybody what what i
think goes wrong
is the history of that community what
what came up in in in our in our kind of
thing uh our kind of findings was
this issue of trust now if you go back
to like the win rush period and then and
then there was
when i grew up he was in the 70s that
was kind of a rebel pier with the police
and those two kind of periods of kind of
i would say quite heavy trauma for a
community yeah you know
because if you look if you can imagine
you you come all the way from
jamaica or trinidad or barbados no
you haven't you've been begged to come
up with people asked you to come here
yeah
yeah and then you land here you get all
this crap you know immediately
no don't come here don't go back home
but you've been asked to come here
i mean it's really interesting about
migration this must be
this set of people must be the
historically for britain enoch powell
went on a campaign
to the caribbean and begged people to
come over there to britain
one of the things that was interesting
when my parents came here this isn't
dynamics about poverty is that um
they were surprised to see how poor
white people were
they were shocked because they thought
all white people were were rich
so they didn't that that thing was that
stung in their heads
and and i think that whole issue goes on
about
it's translated to this horrible word
called white privilege
because they still think that nothing
bad could happen to white people somehow
they're blessed
with this kind of thing of privilege
from the gods or something
and i i do think that that resonates so
you come into the country and you get
this bad experience
then your kids get crap in school as
well you know
and the police and all of that so you
have a community
that looks very much like an
african-american one as well it looks
like it's
one that's out of you know completely
out of
outside of the society because it has
this mental thing about
we can't trust it at all unless you have
and you have the anti-vac thing which is
interesting because
oh i we can't trust it because we can't
trust anything the government
because they're giving it for free and
that couldn't be right you know and so
there's that there's that kind of thing
that you compare that
to the more recent arrived sort of west
african
per summer from nigeria and we call it
immigrant optimism
that comes in and just see well they
haven't got all that
historic baggage at all they just come
in and say wow
right free education wow let's go for it
teachers pens books things that you have
to pay for
back home or whatever it's all free you
know
and you you get paid i mean in my day
when you know
you actually actually paid you to go to
university and he's a bit different now
but um you know so all these these
resources are there for you
and so the mentality is go for it and so
those
those young people from from those
african backgrounds
we'll have parents and people around
them saying look
you've got there is no there is no
history here just work hard
and do well and they are and they are
doing well yeah
tony isn't there another factor here
there as well which people who who are
critics of yours would want to talk
about a lot which is the legacy of
slavery
the the afro-caribbean community are by
by
definition descended from slaves who
were taken to
north america and the caribbean right
whereas the west african probably
wasn't descended and so that
generational
disadvantage the legacy of i don't buy
that you don't buy that no no
here's here's the thing i spent half of
my life in jamaica yes
i'm lucky i have the two places to go to
so i'll be whizzing off soon away from
this cold place it's really warm now but
um so and one of the interesting things
is about class and about it's about
class and poverty
if you look at the migration to
america from say like jamaica and you go
to the unit
there's a university called the
university of west indies 80 of the
graduates
don't stay you know once they've got
their degrees they go to the us
those graduates will and people
professionally as well
will go in and they occupy top jobs in
america
so what you've got is a caribbean middle
class
that's that they're they're the doctors
they're the lecturers
i mean um more than lectures professors
they're running things you know
and so you've got a solid um
black middle class that is that that's
been going to america all the time they
haven't been coming
here what what what happened here was
basically you know people came here in
the 1950s there were poorer
and stayed poor ish yeah
and and was linked really to the white
working class that was here
and and and that's been it's the
socio-economic issue
and the way they were treated when they
were that's right yeah that's right
whereas in fact
it's a quite interesting tension now
it's you know it's quite interesting
when you compare
what goes on towards the us from the
caribbean compared to what went on
migration towards the uk
african americans sometimes are quite
resentful of caribbeans they they look
at them
as almost like the elite almost like you
would say like for example
the indian population here for example
they looked at as an elite
ish kind of proposition over there so
it's a
so the slavery thing is interesting i'm
not saying it's a factor
but you can see that what what's what's
is driving i think is how you then
um come into a country how you migrate
into a country
and then how if if you are going to be
socially mobile
inside that country what happened to my
community we just got stuck
we just got stuck with alongside without
being you know negative here with the
the rest of the white working class
we're here as well we just got stuck
here and i think that um yes you could
talk about there was some more privilege
for those white working-class people but
essentially they were already stuck as
well
they were stuck so slavery is a factor
but it's not it's not the driver here
it's always about so it
there was there is something inside
britain about
how it allows people to actually move
through the gears
fast and how how you can get stuck
in this and and what are the what are
the reasons why
our school system was one of the reasons
why we got so stuck
because it it it operated on a level
where
if you didn't pass your 11 plus or
whatever i mean it happens in capability
as well
or you know you were stuck in these
secondary schools i was stuck in one of
those as well
and and to get out of those things was
hard you know
um and then and then it had i mean i
when i went to university
five percent of the population from four
backgrounds went to university
only five it was just it was a middle
class kind of
you know kind of you know you know
provision it wasn't for poor people only
recently
we've been going to university in big
numbers since blair opened it up
so we've got we so the issues and this
is what comes back to
the issue about my report was that what
was dangerous for me
in the report and what why i've been the
black satan as it were
oh yeah the black christ on the cross
wherever i am
um was that i dared bring class into
this man
i dared bring family and all these other
elements into the racing because all
they wanted to hear was pure race
and they wanted the thing they wanted to
run from slavery right the way through
to racism and it's
not that it's not that simple you see
you see and it's a very very good point
you're saying it's not that simple
why do you think we're just constantly
obsessed
with wanting an easy solution to complex
problems because we don't want solutions
you see the people
inside what's what's actually happened
here
is that there are people who actually
don't want
be straightforward don't want solutions
you see
somehow it's the perpetuation of the
problem
actually suits them it's a really
strange mentality
because when you ask them and this is
the thing about the report that i think
people don't like is
the 24 recommendations are progressive
they're radical
yeah and they're about solutions give us
a flavor tony again for people who
haven't read the report what are some of
the key recommendations well the first
one to kick off which is which is the
one that
that's interesting is that we ask
the equalities and human human rights
commission
who are the police really for racism the
the
the agency that's that that deals with
all of that
we want them to be more robust and have
more powers
so that was the first recommendation and
then we said on top of that that you've
got to do with the online racism that's
going on as well
that marcus rashford and all these other
people are talking about now
where and i asked both of you did a
report
that was meant to be um on race
and ethnic disparity recommending that
the
the the agency that actually does
deal with racism has more powers and
that the government have got to deal
with online racism
that that is the first recommendation
how did that come
to be marked as denying racism
you know where did they lost their heads
and
what i think has happened that's one
recommendation but we didn't stop there
we went after the robots as well
because the ai and all artificial
intelligence
all the kinds of things that you would
do in terms of coding
that could be biased we asked the
government look into that
and make some changes like insurance
things like that how you how you
calculate all these other things
we we wanted that whole so that's deep
seated kind of racism you're going after
there
so when people began that that's a
recognition too and i can keep going
yeah i mean i'll come to a couple in a
minute but if you just pick up those two
yeah um
i i suggest what happened here was that
we caught
friendly fire and it was unfriendly
if you see what i mean so the people who
thought
has come back that in fact the
recommendations were going to be soft or
whatever
didn't know or didn't want to know that
the first recommendation that came out
was about anti-racism it was about that
so what this government's got to do and
since why this is why i don't really
understand where
the criticism could have come from
because it it
you know the labour party would love
this
you know it's it's for them you you you
have a recommendation that's saying that
that agency has got to be tougher have
more resources
go after on and already the government
are doing it because they're changing
the law now but
now we're going to have to have facebook
we're going to have to have twitter
really be serious about this otherwise
they're going to get fined heavily
yeah and so um that's what we
recommended
hold on tony but aren't you being a bit
naive if you don't mind me saying so
about why people were critical because
they were critical because they wanted
you to come out
and say the country is institutionally
racist the police are all racist
the education system is racist employers
are racist
uh because that's the world view that
they they already have and they wanted
you to confirm that and when you didn't
that's why they got angry
i think you've got the world record for
racist in one question
but but but you know you go with the
evidence i've i've painted it
more complex but these people don't go
with the evidence though yeah i mean
i've painted a more com
i've painted a more nuanced picture than
that yeah and then
and you you have to you have to and look
it doesn't
solve the problems you see for example
if you
there is racism in the police and that
and that's a fact and we've got
strong recommendations for that but you
can't then just say that
if you're gonna if you're gonna deal
with the issue of the family
you have to have a recommendation to
somebody specific for that and deal with
that and not
not not kind of dodge it because in the
end you can just say
okay let's have let's let's do more
unconscious bias training in schools
if you think all teachers are racist
that would try that it's a complete
waste of time
yeah because the problem isn't with the
with the with the teachers in in that
regard
that the issue is with the capacity of
the family
to deal with some of these problems and
what so what we did we brought our
recommendation that said we want
and this is a very strong one government
think hard about that
we want a task force for the family
that's gonna give
so in the end what will happen is in
real
in real terms those those african
caribbean
mothers or or lone parents will get will
actually get more resources
as a result of this report i mean i mean
it it's just as
as flatlined as that they will get more
help for that
but but but we we won't we won't say oh
we're going to have more trainers coming
to teach and tell them how
trying to pull out the races about their
heads or something i don't know but
that's not working
you know that's not because that's not
where the problem lies because african
children are just doing really well in
that system and and
and um flourishing in it and so
you just have to go where the evidence
takes you it's not about
um bias or and you're right
those those things that people wanted me
you to say and didn't say that's that's
the thing you know
and he didn't they really didn't want a
complex nuanced thing about this they
just wanted just you just just to yell
you know the world is racist and uh and
that's
and a lot and a lot of companies went
along with this as well and they kind of
just
because it suited them to kind of say
well look we will put our george floyd
kind of thing on our black power thing
on our kind of logo tomorrow and i go
back and do the same practice
because black people are not progressing
in those organizations either
you see so it doesn't matter how kind of
you know you put out these gestures
it doesn't make any difference because
the real issue around um
progression as well is in those in those
companies you could argue well
you know okay is it racism that's
stopping
those people progressing or there's
something else that's going on
you know and then you look at back to
what i said about this history of this
group
and what happens in there and how you
feel in a sense do i belong here do i
really belong here
and then if the opportunity is there are
you
empowering those people to progress
rather than sticking labels on an
organization and saying you are this or
you are that
when in fact the real problem is mate
was part of the problem could be
about getting those people to really now
begin to think about how can i
have the confidence to go through
this this difficult organization and i
think that
that that really is the problem but it's
also as well tony i mean
let's be fair wind rush did a tremendous
amount of damage
to you know particularly caribbean
people's trust in the government do you
not think
it was just another example for them of
them being let down by the government
and it's still happening now yeah i
agree and i think that
what you've got to do is you've got to
not put people
i mean one of the things in the report
that i think was really good is that
it didn't only just land it on one area
this is one of the
things that people think oh you're only
on this side and you don't look at the
other argument
and and because it's nuanced and complex
racism exists so we're not saying that
it's not an element we're not saying
that teachers aren't racist either
but you have to look at where it lands
so when russia is is a
is a key aspect of it in terms of
something that went wrong and something
that that definitely
has has elements of racism in there but
but even there you see what's what's
what's sad about the windrush is that
it it only is known for the fact that
uh for now for a legacy this this was
the thing that
that where people got ripped off it's
not known for the rich
legacy of caribbean people it's not
labeled with that
so again you've got to try we've got to
try and think of another way
of getting some balance there because it
it isn't only about
those people getting ripped off it's
also about
the contributions of my parents
generations the positive ones you see
so yes but you are right and
what you've got to do is almost go down
a twin track with this
and say there are other nuanced issues
that you've got to deal with
and you also got to deal with the
institution and that's why
we've put these recommendations out for
right the
number one is the body that polices this
thing
is gonna get fully loaded you know i
mean you cannot
i mean anybody's seen that first
recommendation
what on earth why are these people
jumping up in there you know that's
that that's a key recommendation from
what you're talking about
let's talk about policing because one of
the things i took away from my first
interview with you
is how balanced you are as you are now
you were then and you talked about your
own experience growing up in this
country when
you know a black man had committed a
crime suddenly everybody within a
you know an area was being arrested or
stopped by the police
so you know and we know friends we've
got friends in comedy or whatever who
will talk about
by the time i was 25 i'd been stopped by
the police 15
20 times so what were some of your
findings and some of your resulting
recommendations in that area which i
think is a concern to a lot of people
yeah i mean the policing one was an
interesting one because what we did that
was really about
trust and again keep coming back to this
community that
it's not that african people aren't
going to get stopped as well but
that trust element for for a community
along the years
especially in the 70s the police have
you know
got to do a lot of catching up and so
what we what we found was that
the building of that trust was was
needed so what you needed to do really
was
give um the community a sense that the
police
was a service rather than a force and
they they were actually part
of you know the policing themselves you
know
um there are some issues though about
how you do that
um if so we came up with with
safeguarding task force which was a kind
of
um safeguarding group which was this
this this sort of
it's a group that actually can hold the
police commissioners
can hold the um you know those who
are in in the top management of police
they come to that group and they have to
then
regularly explain how they're doing what
their operations are so the community
itself has a power
over that that that group and that that
was key
one but we we wanted to find so we
wouldn't find very practical
recommendations not theoretical ones
one of the ones also we insisted is that
the police turn on their
um the um video
that they have the the body cams yeah
and
that in fact that would be a compulsory
because at the moment
there's it seems to be like it's
voluntary though oh i forgot to turn it
on
so but you have to have it on all the
time and that that's a key element in
terms of people feeling secure
about that that interaction i think the
other one
that is interesting is there's some of
the training around police and i've seen
this in teaching as well
de-escalation training you know how you
you know in you know you go
you saw that interaction that you have
to do with young people how do you make
that better so the training has got to
be
much much more focused the two radical
ones which are which the government will
find hard but they're going for
and that and i think this is the one
that people again are surprised when
they see it
is we've insisted on what we call
residency this is to make the police
more represent representative of of of
the area that you're in so for example
it if you're at the moment we have
a police force that is um
particularly on the white side i mean
the asian side is a bit more balanced
there's hardly any black people actually
in london
the numbers are really small at the
moment and so there's a
40 000 uplift that that they've been now
given and so to get more officers
so what we want what we've directed
is that the police officers have to come
from the area
you know that you you live in so you if
you're going to join the police you're
going to join them from in your area so
in and that would say for example if you
look at an area like tottenham
or or lambeth then we have to have
police officers
who live in that area joining i mean
exclusively but they
they will get now that's a significant
change because that will mean
that the actual force the complexion of
the force will change because it will
represent the communities
that's radical um and um the mets have
already taken that up as a and they're
going for 40 they're going to
increase that and i know christopher
dick has said that she wants to do that
so but we want it across the country so
it doesn't say
it don't get me wrong if you're in
cornwall
you know it doesn't mean that you have
to find you know a thousand black
officers
you know but um but but but if you're in
a situation
but if you but if if but if you are in
tottenham which at the moment
is you know you go out there or in
croydon
and probably 90 of the officers are
white and the
the community is is 80 ethnic minority
it doesn't reflect that so what we're
saying is that that should change
people have asked me is that um
affirmative action backdoor no
but it's it's it's actually looking at
the skill set
of that community and saying that it
should reflect that yeah
but if we don't stop there one of the
other radical ones is
to do with um the possession possession
of class b drugs
now what what's actually happened is
that because um
black communities are over policed when
those police officers go on
looking for say knives or whatever the
the
um issue is that sony can i just stop
you there i know it's a very important
point you're making but i just want to
i'm i'm listening to you through the
eyes of a critic to some extent and i
want to say
well you say they're over policed why
are they overpoliced
well this is it they're over police
because
we have a situation where 24
times more likely to die really of
homicide black males are
likely to be victims of homicide
compared
to their white counterparts
so that's 24 times more as a black man
you're likely to die of homicide or or
somebody's death but i mean i mean we're
talking really about
knife crime we're talking about a murder
yeah i said it with hesitancy but that's
it 24 times more than any other group
it's probably the most
kind of um you know for us in terms of
findings
we were we were almost in tears with
that one because
why why we were moved by that was nobody
really cares
and i say that and i don't say that
flippantly i
i think that we've reached a point with
knife crime twenty
one community one set of ethnicity
24 times uh getting homicide
compared to the majority compared to the
white population
nobody really cares and i say that
because
we've reached a kind of point now where
we're fairly indifferent
about another black youth dying of knife
crime we just say well you know
we just expect and what oh here's where
the difference gets even more
interesting
in london when you hear about a knife
crime you automatically think it's a
black person
two black kids doing it you don't even
think twice you don't think it could
be a white person you just think
everybody everybody in the newsroom
everybody thinks oh
it's gonna be two black kids doing this
or a group of black kids on another one
and so we've reached a point of
indifference in this
that's that that's unacceptable why is
it tony
that and we and i agree with you like
you know
when i was a teacher i was a teacher in
europe which has
a huge gang problem and i remember one
of my students telling me
that he was in trouble and he was going
through a bit of former students
and telling me that they were looking to
remove him from one school to the next
and i said are you happy about that
fresh start all the rest of it and he
went no
because i'm gonna they'll murder me why
is it that we get more upset
about some poor unfortunate soul being
murdered
in minneapolis than we do about young
black boys dying
in our own city i'm not going to i'm not
going to be
pushed in because i can see a headline
coming here
and i'm not going to i'm not going to
answer the question how you put
it right because i don't want
journalists listening to this to try and
do a sneaky on me yeah
but when i think of the collection come
on come on yeah
though um what what i will say is what i
said before
about the fact that we've become
you know kind of cold to this now
because
it's too it's too close to home and we
can't we don't actually when it comes to
solutions you see
we don't know what to do that's that's
right yeah we think we think there's
nothing that can be that's right that's
right and and
in a sense it's it's that that's the
problem here
in in a way that has become and i've
written about this before in the past as
you know
and it's and it's become a an issue for
us um
that that we can't i mean i mean
i i i'm more kind of worried
not so much about the solutions to it
but the the fact that people just
accept it and who said who i'm really
crossed with
is the bbc we really want it unless
everyone's having a guidance let's take
another piece out of them now
and i think that their attitude towards
for example
um what i've seen when it's been
reported
that the way they report these things is
interesting because
there is there is a sense in which
they're not they're not delving into
the reasons why they're not they're
almost frightened to go
there and and talk about some of the
community dynamics around this
and um and and also my community's
probably embarrassed by it
and and also there's another thing it's
easier to in a sense
it's all about devils really to find
that devil again in the white person
and and and the white community or
whatever it is or the white privilege
but when it when it when it comes home
it's just it
you know it's like oh what am i going to
do is i'm help
and and then so what they what what
i've heard some things that people put
it on cuts
you know you know kind of cuts in terms
of grants and things like that you know
and and austerity people trying to find
desperately trying to find
different things to explain you know and
it's not i mean actually we've got some
data that showed that actually knife
crime was at its height
when austerity was eight at the bottom
where
that were labor are impounded there was
no austerity a knife crime peaked
there was no relationship really between
the two things
so we come back to um well there is a
relationship in one way i i
can't contradict myself there's a
relationship yes in terms of some
poverty
and i think there is but there's also
another thing going on because you can't
just
lay on poverty alone that has to be to
do with
maybe stuff in the family maybe stuff
also to do with some mental health
issues
and i think i think also there are some
cultural factors as well all of those
things wrapped up
and in the police you when i interrupted
you before you were saying
because the black community is over
police and we've you've now explained
why because there is this problem going
on right
because of that more people are stopped
and therefore more people are found to
have drugs and then people end up with
criminal records
that's right that's exactly what we've
done so in order to avoid that problem
for in well i say innocent but certainly
black kids who are just not involved in
knife crime but get caught with
possession
what we're saying and it's a strong
recommendation and a radical one
is that they should be diverted to
something else in a sense of diversion
activities but not having a criminal
record
because that's the problem you're
getting so so many black youngsters
being caught in this problem and and it
wouldn't happen to you if you were a
student at oxford university
right because you wouldn't be so over
policed yeah so they wouldn't catch you
with them
and they probably take more drugs than
anybody yeah yeah so
it's it's so it's a question of fairness
so and also
that they probably get better lawyers or
whatever and and those
kids we don't want them to have a
criminal record
so what we've do we've asked to go down
the health route we want
something there's got to be a
consequence you can't just have to
be possessed because we're not doing
down decriminalization but we're saying
that the consequence
we we hope will not be criminal
you know a criminal justice one in a
sense but it will be a health one
and um and obviously you have to admit
your guilt
so in a sense and i and the police have
welcomed this funny enough they
you know it wasn't just something of
course they don't want to run around
locking up people who've got a bag of
weed in their pockets
and also take something they can deal
with that quickly and then move on to
trying to find the real knives and the
real criminals
i mean there was some push back on this
but we're not naive we
we know that a lot of kids are out there
with those bags of
weed or whatever and they're selling it
we do know that we're not naive
keith fraser uh 30 you know over 30
years of policing
it was one of the commissioners he
understands all of that however
we balance that with the idea that you
know this
there is this you know kind of almost
um stream of kids going into the
criminal justice system and then once
they're
in there then that's worse because they
get caught up in in other things and
so that was a way of stopping it so look
you you get to that one
and you ask where on earth did this
backlash on the report come
because so far i've outlined some stuff
that even a labor government would sweat
on
you know so i again i i come back to
this idea that they didn't they
they gave us friendly fire because of
who we were
they thought that we were there was a
there was a preconception that they
thought that this was going to be
we were just going to chuck the
government some easy things to do
and uh and we were controlled by the
government when in fact we were
we were fiercely independent and um
we are giving them a heart you know we
we've put something in here called
the extended school day you know that's
going to cost
government millions of pounds you
imagine giving
but the reason why we put the extended
school day was to help those single
parents
because you know if you think about a
single parent now if she knows that her
her son is her daughter is going to have
an extended school day that means they
can do debating they can do
make films like you guys they can do
things that will help their social
mobility in that extended time
now who's going to pay for that you know
so this
these are interventionist things dare i
say socialist things that
that are in the recommendation um the
thing is as left as anything
you know and and um and so this is
you can see my sort of how kind of
frustrated i am with it because in a way
what they've done
is they've sent a message to communities
about
something that is going to help them and
only because they didn't say it or
whatever
or they didn't read it or they didn't
want to know
they've they've made the thing negative
when in fact what should be happening
now is everybody should be getting
behind these recommendations
and really and really kind of pushing
the government and making sure that
they're going to put it in place
hey francis do you think it's cool that
the same company that controls 50
of online retail also passively
eavesdrops on every conversation you
have in your home
what what about the idea that a single
company controls
90 of internet searches and gets to
track
everything you do on your smartphone i'm
so
screwed you are trigonometry is now
going to be a solo project
big tech is more powerful than most
countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data
it is time to put a layer of protection
between your online activity
and these tech juggernauts that is why i
use expressvpn
unfortunately so sadly every site you
visit every video you watch
every message you send gets tracked and
data mined but
when you run expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
something big tech can use to personally
identify you so
expressvpn makes your activity harder to
trace and sell to advertising
absolutely and the best part is how easy
it is to use
download the app on your phone or
computer tap just one button
and you're protected francis please stop
crying my new shoes are getting wet
if you don't want to end up like me and
want to protect yourself from big tech
go to expressvpn.com
trigger and get three extra months for
free
that's e x p r e
s s v p and dot com
slash trigger to learn more
[Music]
and do you sometimes get frustrated with
people particularly on the labour party
who purport to have those communities
interests at heart
and then they do or say what like the
examples that you've given
and actually they're not helping their
community you see
this is where again i i i i'm going to
be very political here and say that
harriet hartman came on and she she
liked what we were doing you know
we hated it now i don't know what she's
going to say but she was quite
interesting and people
oh harriet harmon but but but she could
see where this was going and what she
really liked
was giving them teeth to
um the equalities and human rights
commission making them look like the old
cre
real kind of just go for racism do you
know get that online stuff stopped
so there clearly are people inside that
party
that want to do things that are positive
but they've got themselves in a mess and
particularly with the hartley pool thing
as well
where they appear to not even like
working-class people you know it's a
strange thing for a party you know
cold labor yeah well i'm not party
political i'm independent of that
but i'm just saying that they what what
here's where i think it's a good
good thing for labor to do if they were
really kind of focused what they should
get behind this report
and really push the government say look
this is a really solid report
and you you you've commissioned are you
going to put these things in play
yeah um so um
yeah that's so so for us you know that
was where it is but
but but the policing thing is is an
interesting one
which if if this report results in
more black and ethnic particularly more
black police
on the beat going on there and actually
also not on the beat but
progressing in that force and coming up
there and
you know detectives and things like that
they're there but they just need to be
there in more number
you know and i think it's a it's and
it's a it's an interesting area for the
community to
it's not that you know black kids need
to be policed by
people who look like them but they've
got to see somebody
that looks like you you know and um and
you know the police want this to happen
the government wanted something we are
giving them a kick up the backside and
saying that you've got to do it now
you've got to mandate this
you know it's got to happen but it's
also as well when
the thing that i found very interesting
was talking about stop and search
yeah now we we we we've we've because of
this thing but what
the issue that we some people are saying
you should
subsearch doesn't have any kind of you
know
positive outcome it's it it makes black
youth
kind of feel depressed and and they're
pressured by it
and there's racism involved we agree all
of these things happen
but on the day when
for example there was a case where where
one poor kid was stabbed 48 times and if
you come across that case
by a bunch a couple of kids 48 times you
know
and um that lone parent or that
that may not be alone parent could be um
you know not that case um
but the the family or whoever's around
that boy
they would want us to go off on that
evening that same night
and find those knives and find those
criminals those
perpetrators of those crimes so in a way
it's almost like the police have to use
that tactic and we say
fair enough but do it properly do it
fairly
do it in a manner that doesn't also
criminalize those
kids that you find on route who've got
some weed you know
so all of those elements make sure your
you know your body cam is on
you know um use dizzy escalation tactics
when you're doing it
you know um so i think that
we want it but we want it done fairly it
sounds like a lot of the things you're
talking about are
a way of just adjusting elements of the
current system to improve it
to make it better uh and i think maybe
that's where
some of the sort of unfair pushback has
come is where people have just want you
to tear the system down and build
a great new utopia in this place it
certainly seemed that way to me
but i want to move on a little bit tony
and talk about the media's role in all
of this because
um you know what did you make of the way
that this report was covered by the by
journalists whose job it is to to give
an objective reading of
of what you've presented yeah i mean i
think what happened here
again it comes back to the the prejudice
around the report it was clear that
some sections of the media wanted to
take it down before it was even
written because they they didn't really
like the fact that
who was composed in in there myself
whatever
why not why don't they like because
because maybe they thought
that i was just um some patsy for the
conservative party
right yeah and and and they're wrong you
know they didn't they didn't they didn't
think it through so what happened was
they went they put resources to towards
trying to sort of bring it down and they
never really addressed any it's very
interesting they never addressed any of
the recommendations
there's there's one in there for office
for health disparity
which we've never had in this country
before which really is gonna
it's gonna you know significantly help
um black and ethnic minorities live
longer and and and be healthier
you know because you've got a targeted
now agency that's going to do that
and um you know i think
they they conceded that that wasn't bad
[Laughter]
so it's hard to just it's hard to
describe the media because to be honest
there are other sections of the media
that
really came out and said they were for
this and it was much needed
yeah and of course others didn't
um i was disappointed by the bbc their
coverage of this i'll name them because
i think they need to be
they they did they didn't come back and
look at those recommendations
i mean one of the things that the the
media missed which i
if i was a journalist i just don't know
why they didn't go after us
which was this whole issue of the class
to be drugs i mean that is a massive
story
yeah because you you're teething on so
so
why did they miss a government
recommendation about
the fact that young people are
could be in a position now where the
police are gonna not
put them in the criminal justice system
but but divert them
or you know why would you why would you
miss that just to go on
some kind of i don't know journey about
language that we use around race
you see they're so obsessed with
identity politics
that they even missed the juicy story in
the report
you know this this is this is the kind
of
thing that is strange there were so many
stories inside that
inside those recommendations do you
think that's part of the problem that we
now view everything
through the lens of identity politics
that we can't really be objective
anymore
no or even see something that that looks
like a great story for you
it just blocks everything and so what
what what it was was there were the bad
guys over there that
that basically they don't they don't
believe in racism whatever they're
they're the deniers and and and i hate
to say this
in a sense but a significant amount of
white journalists on a
from from a particular point of view
we're going to police that
you know until tell the rest of the
community what they should hear
and i think that's that that's really
what was going on and
and and then then the community just
hears these things
it gets on on the twitter artie and
that's it you know
this this is a this is the this is these
are the groups of people that
deny the reality of racism when in fact
they actually the first recommendation
was to strengthen the body
that police is racism i mean you could
as i said you couldn't make you don't
you know and that and and so so to me
yeah we're in a we're in a crazy place
at the moment and do you think that
this report and the the legislation
that's going to be put in place is going
to help to
calm things down or do you think that
we've gone
i mean not through the looking glass but
almost halfway through
here's the irony of the whole thing
which which makes me kind of feel
confident and happy
funny enough because of this the
controversy around it
and and the whole thing the government
are going to be
really you know pressured now to look
serious at these recommendations
so i actually think in a strange sort of
way i'm hoping
i'm fingers crossed to get full house on
this
so in a way you know for me it's great
and i
i believe that we might have we may have
to have a part three here where i come
back
because they're coming back to i've
never seen record time
july that's record time for any
commission
most of these people do they have to
wait three years to get here or anything
if they do
we're we're in july to hear it
so um and i i my expectations are high
that we will get so what's the result
the racism is particularly online marcus
rashford's gonna be really happy
you know um well he they lost
football he's one he's one on
he's one on on on the kind of online
racism yeah
i mean you know i mean i mean the less
black kids are going to get in the
criminal justice system
you're going to have a situation where
more black single mothers are going to
get more cash in their hands or whatever
they're going to get
you're going to have a an office for
health disparities to look at the real
health conditions around black and i
think minority people and white working
class people generally
i mean you know you have a whole kind of
range of um
uh you know significant practical
solutions
which is this is the thing you see
nobody wants to go down oh we could we
could we could actually put some
answers to some of these things at least
no we don't want it we want to come back
to
identities and stuff like that and uh
you know
um you know training for this and
whatever you know
well there's people making a few quid
out of it yeah that's right and i think
that's
that's that's the problem you know we've
got an industry here
and so and i think that those people
all know now i always want to appeal to
just ordinary people yeah who
can see the common sense and see that
they will
benefit or not that's how you judge it
you know and i
and and and um we're going to force this
government to do that we're not
we're not patsy with this government
they're going to have a hard time
putting this across the line i believe
me you know
a conservative government diverting you
know
drugs possession is unheard of
yeah well i know your hands are probably
somewhat tight or maybe you don't
like the the war on drugs is something
that i think is
is not a good idea personally and i've
we've talked about this with others
a lot uh and uh you can totally see how
not criminalizing people for
possession of drugs that they're not
even trying to speed drugs
how that would help um you mentioned
america
uh we do you think a lot of the way that
we seem to have
started to have these conversations in a
way that i i don't think we used to have
in this country do you think a lot of
that is just
taking the american discourse and just
importing it importing it here
yes absolutely i think that
particularly in my sector the university
sector they could be so careful
they've got to be so careful because
yeah you know i i our universities are
great places you know
and and i really enjoyed being in them
amongst them but we just got to be so
careful that
we don't i think what what's gone wrong
is that they think they're plea
i think something to do is also with
that nine grand as well i mean that that
is
a big issue that the the students the
power that the students have with that
they pay therefore
that's really what's going on here
believe me if the students weren't
paying this
we having this conversation i really i
think that's the driver here
and i think they think that the students
want
so there's a sort of sense that they
don't want to
almost kind of uh you know injure the
students
you know in terms of their sense of
identity and what they were
so they're trying to please everybody
and it has end up pleading anybody
really
and i think lecturers also got to be
careful in this as well
so and that comes from the american
campus coming here
you know as well so i do think that we
should be more robust in that and
and and it's i'm not somebody who and
again i get caricatured as some someone
who is
who doesn't i mean i who doesn't think
that there's a should be a balance here
i do think
i do think that universities should you
know
there there are there are times when you
know
there could be people who who are not
welcome but
very rarely i would say that's very rare
you know so
um yes i think you're right it is coming
a bit from the us i do think that um
we should we should be careful about
that and i do think that that's
something that
i'm hoping that the uk now this this
this report really in a sense is doing
is looking at the uk lens and what and
i've
as i've spoken about the nuances all of
you both of you have recognized
things that are inside the uk but um
nuances that we know about inside you
know
that and it's not it's not the same as
america some of it's similar but it's
not the same you know
the way in which class operates here you
know and the way in which we
you know our schooling system and
everything else either it
there are similarities but the
differences as well tony you talk about
history a little bit when you were
talking about
quote-unquote your community
afro-caribbeans coming here
uh et cetera history has been a big
topic over the last year in this country
in in relation to race in particular
uh what are your thoughts on on some of
the conversations that are being had
about that
the importance of teaching history
through a particular angle
or focusing on certain things or
avoiding certain things or whatever like
what what have you made of that debate
well one of the things that is
interesting with
and i can see a particular way in which
history
i mean in a strange sort of way i i got
a i could have really
it wasn't a bad i mean i had a crap
school but i mean the history stuff was
quite good and what
what happened was that we had an old
marxist to talk towards history which
was great really because
more and more beginning you would have
believed that maybe maybe i'm just a
closet marxist because because you know
what he did was um christopher hill all
these other people
what those kind of historians they they
looked at the industrial revolution
you know and saw that there were
parallels i mean
it's not like for light there's no way
was it the same but we were taught about
the fact that working-class people in
this country from
women working in you know in the 19th
century in
in those horrible kind of making matches
in in
the bright may factories to kids going
up
chimneys to the factories in manchester
and all of those kinds of industrial
revolutions were gone
as well as the slavery that was that was
in the caribbean and
and so we we got a range of britain
really
as an imperial force that was fairly
negative in our sense and we got we got
that and we understood that and it
wasn't we had a good
but we had great debates around it so we
we were well schooled on that
and and and what was clear was that
there were
there were drivers of class and race
going on at the same time
i mean we got that that notion in in
terms of history
what history has become a bit is it
slipped into the identity politics
element now because you
because what what tends to happen is
you're teaching people history
because you want them to feel good you
know what i mean so
so what happens is the history becomes
like a psychological
kind of thing so it's not really history
about facts and understanding how things
happen dynamic
what what you you're trying to solve
a couple of problems at the same time
and they're not really the same problem
so
because on people's sense of feeling
mistrust to the society and their
trauma around dealing with britain i
think that should be dealt with
separately almost than
what you do in a in history because in
it
and we've come up in in in the report
with the making of modern britain so
what we've tried to do is is produce a
history
that looks at the complex again
involvement of britain in terms of the
empire
but also in terms of some of the
positives as well you know
you just work the two things together
but also we want to look at local
history as well for working class white
kids
what you know what's the history of
lancashire what's the history of
you know middlesborough you know what's
your local history so you get a sense of
and then the kids in um middlesborough
learning about perhaps what happened in
the caribbean
and the kids in in in brixton learning
about you know the history of
lancashire you know it says it's it's
it's a whole sort of sense of
and then of course ancestral histories
as well lots of things
we want a lexicon around indian words
that come you know sort of words that
are
that have come from subcontinent into
into the modern language
the the positive influences that you
have so
i think the answer to the question is
that
um i i i think what we we need to do is
have a better
he's not changing the curriculum but
have a better sense of
the forces that make modern britain and
they're complex and they're interesting
and they're not always negative so it's
not just let's
kick out let's burn all the books that
are to do with dead white men
and and then leave leave leave all the
rest
to look at it's not it's not that
process at all it's actually
looking at the influences so for example
i'll give you one example of this which
is interesting
we we caribbean writers came over here
in the 1950s lots of them
and a lot of their influences were was
shakespeare
was was the classics were if you look at
their you know if you look at
the books that they read and and who
they were influenced look at their biogs
they're very they have a positive view
even though they were
anti-colonialists at the same time they
acknowledge the influence of britain on
them yeah
so you you can't then just indoctrinate
kids to say look
all of this was a bunch of evil and all
of all of this is just good
it's it's it's a complex mixture of of
both things coming together
and i think that's so that's how i would
like us to see history and it's also
about acknowledging that okay the
british empire did do a lot of bad
but you know what all empires do the
ottomans weren't one yeah
no they didn't talk about intersectional
identity politics
neither did you know dangerous khan all
the rest of it what you've got to do
with this
is and um
it's really tr i heard somebody say once
a teacher says that
he he was prided himself on teaching
history
where there was no european contact and
i said
i was wondering what does that mean so
what he wanted to do was teach the kids
about
africa pre-slavery and
and what what he missed there was i i
agree i think there was
you can teach history pre-slavery and
you go into into another history and
once about i don't know
egyptians and and pyramids and things
like that which is interesting i think
there is and
and he felt that the kids needed to
understand history
that was that that was longer and that
was that was stronger
you know to be then that was blacker you
know really that's really what we're
talking about
and and in effect that kind of dodges
some things
because i used to teach um in the
caribbean and here
and in and what i realized about um
caribbean kids was they were much more
confident than my
my kids here the same year and when i
looked at the history curriculum what
they did was they didn't dodge slavery
what they did was they actually talked
about how
in jamaica in particular people retained
their humanity
within the inhumanity so for example
you you open up those slave ledgers and
you see um
all that that the accountant would have
um you know the pigs the goats and then
somebody named [ __ ]
who and so they're all kind of that so
the slave that enslaved african was just
part of
like the stock that was there the
livestock
now the the truth of the matter is that
my ancestors were not animals
and what you what you needed then is a
history that talked about
how they um almost retained their
humanity
through dance through um the way they
cooked
the way they dressed as a whole social
history religion as well
religion as well um everything coming in
to
and and that that history is important
so that people could understand
and also how that influenced the present
and so what i
noticed that they were doing that
history in the caribbean so and also how
they resisted slavery that's the key
thing
because yeah you know if you if you were
just an animal then you just accept it
but you weren't
you know so so and so knowing about sam
sharp and all these other
so there's a constant resistance to
slavery as well
so what you have then is is is not
dodging it
but actually and you don't dodge also
the fact that the british made
loads of money and and exploited people
and
you don't just dodge the horrors of it
but you also talk about that piece of
the humanity
inside that and i think that's the key
way in which you then
bring that through you know so that you
end up with
um a very proud people because they've
they've been
you've seen the legacy of it you know
and uh yeah you do end up with a history
that shows
you you know the the the ways in which
that community was pressured but also
you end up seeing how they
were involved in their own emancipation
and the thing that the the slavery
couldn't take away from them was their
imaginations
and their minds and that was that was
the key element that they taught
so i think that back to that teacher
yes you know but if you were just if you
were just dodging
he didn't have the resources or the kind
of sense of
of how to to teach that piece so he
thought what i better do i better not
hurt the kids to
make slavery let me let me go back and
and and go for some wakanda sort of
thing where you know we're all kind of
you know some kind of um and and little
does he know that
even i mean i know africa has its
kingdoms and it's and it's some
you know uh you know and it's great
architecture
they also had issues you know because
they're real people you know
it's not a wonderland you know so well i
mean you talk about pre-slavery actually
middle eastern slave traders took more
africans out of africa than the white
colonizers did it's
history is complicated but it is it is
that that's what it is right and that's
how you're going to see one of the
things that people
misunderstood sometimes or misunderstand
is that if you teach the humanity within
the
inhumanity that somehow that's that
glorifies
slavery which doesn't no what is you're
doing is you're saying
wow what a people that actually did um
you know you know endure this and
actually
retained retain their humanity inside
this
um and and and that's important
particular black caribbean kids to
understand that you know
so when they come to that period it's
not just
you know yes the slave ships there yes
people were raped and whatever
but at the same time what else went on
and and the caribbean got that hitch
that social issue so that person
[ __ ] is no longer a kind of derogatory
name it was an animal that's a real
person
yeah yeah that's a very positive message
to end the
the conversation on tony thank you so
much for coming back
i would really appreciate it and i think
that the the new ones with which you
have the conversation
actually just on a personal level i'm
very inspired by the
positive and optimistic approach you
have
so much of the discussion around these
issues is so
negative not focused on finding a
solution just people just want to tear
the whole thing
down and not look to actually improve
people's lives so i commend you for that
and
uh congratulations i hope as you say you
hold the government's fee
to the fire uh get them to implement the
recommendations and look if it's not
enough there'll need to be another
report and more recommendations to be
made right
yeah well thanks for having me no it's a
pleasure and we always finish with the
last question
before uh uh some questions from our
patrons our locals patrons
is what is a what is the one thing we're
not talking about but we really should
be
oh right right what what you should be
talking about
now i suppose is oh
i would say um what we should be talking
about now is class
we should be talking about poverty and
class that's what we should be talking
about
not denying race we should also be
talking about problems don't forget
poverty in class
because those are the those are the real
key drivers i think
and and if we can get over if we can
have that conversation more and more
i think we will find that we'll you know
be beginning to be f
we will find solutions to some of these
things that that take us in a different
place than we are at the moment
well said tony thank you uh thank you
for coming back and thank
you guys for watching we will see you
very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one
see you soon and uh take care guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry
is important support us by joining our
local community
using the link below